cent dix-huit heures et se blesser ceux
qui ont travaillé plus de 78 mais ils
sont ma plus tous les chômeurs
découragés donc moi je maintiens que
c'est pas la soviétisation mais que ça
reste problématique
il faut se rappeler quand même on a le
rsa en france pour les plus pauvres
effectivement le problème c'est un
problème de nos membres ont recours à ce
rsa il n'est pas suffisant mais il
existe et l'autre problème du rsa c'est
qu'il n'est pas accessible aux personnes
de moins de 25 ans
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change il a d'ailleurs
changé entre l'enfance du général de
gaulle et 1969 ce qui ne change pas
c'est la condition humaine et une
certaine idée que la civilisation se
fait de la dignité de la personne
humaine et de sa liberté si vous aviez
deux ou trois mots pour caractériser ce
que vous appelez la méthode l'attitude
l'art de gouverner vous diriez quoi tout
d'abord l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
ça leur est inscrit au dessus du bureau
de chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
deux cibles importantes du groupe etat
islamique neutralisés lors d'une frappe
américaine une autre série est blessé à
lons du pentagone tout à l'heure réponse
à l'attentât suicide de jeudi près de
l'aéroport de kaboul attaque qui a fait
plus d'une centaine de morts dont 13
soldats américains la branche afghane du
groupe des slaves revendiquer les
etats-unis qui ont encore quelques jours
avant de mettre un terme à leur présence
sur le sol afghan et de terminer leurs
opérations d'évacuation
[Musique]
emmanuel macron en irak pour un sommet
régional à la crise afghane est au coeur
des discussions
lutte contre le groupe terroriste état
islamique concernant la présence
française en irak emmanuel macron
l'annoncé tout à l'heure quel que soit
le choix américain la france restera
aussi longtemps que l'irak le demandera
[Musique]
et puis les opposants au pass à lithaire
étaient à nouveau dans la rue pour le
septième à samedi consécutive protester
contre l'extension du pass sanitaires
notamment l'obligation vaccinale pour
certains employés environ 200
manifestations ont eu lieu à travers la
france à paris plusieurs cortèges ont
rassemblé des dizaines de milliers de
personnes
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20 heures
plus que quelques jours avant le retrait
définitif des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan les opérations
d'évacuation depuis l'aéroport de kaboul
où touche également à leurs fins sur
place de nouvelles attaques sont
redoutées après l'attentât suicide de
jeudi qui a fait une centaine de morts
les précisions à kaboul de mourad gaz
dief envoyé spécial pour rt
international
bon votre style est très peu de jours
restant avant la fin de l'évacuation les
tensions sont encore sérieux à kaboul ce
n'est pas aussi tendues aussi mauvais qu
après les explosions de l'aéroport
pourtant les raids antiterroristes
continue en ville
c'est que les mesures de sécurité ont
été intensifiées au plus haut niveau
possible les talibans continuent
toujours de mener des raids en porte à
porte dans toute la ville dans le but
d'identifier d'arrêter le plus de
membres et de soutien de dèche possible
d'ache qui selon eux ont en projet de
nouveaux attentats l'aéroport a sonné à
protéger c'est une opinion partagée par
les talibans par les etats-unis leur
allié ils s'attendent à plus d'un
attentat terroriste ou au moins des
tentatives de cibler les foules à
l'aéroport nous savons qu'une dizaine de
personnes soutenant des ch ont été
arrêtés pendant ces raids dans kaboul
les images de trois personnes ont été
publiés par les talibans et les talibans
promettent de mettre fin à la présence
de daishi 6 à kaboul et sur l'ensemble
du territoire afghan mais c'est quelque
chose qu'ils pourront faire une fois que
les états unis seront partis en boîte
the united states à livre the sky
bagouet d'aller jusqu'à la cellule de
daage qui depuis des années mène une
guerre contre les taliban ici en
afghanistan
considère les talibans comme trop saoul
trop occidentaux est trop libéraux
parmi les victimes de l'explosion
revendiqué par le groupe etat islamique
très soldat américain joe biden avait
promis de traquer les auteurs de cette
attaque la riposte n'a pas tardé le
quant à gonna annoncé que deux cibles
importantes ont été neutralisés il
s'agit d' organisateur et d'opérateurs
une personne également membre de cette
branche locale de dèche a également été
blessé dans cette frappe de drone elle a
été menée dans la province afghane de
nangarhar
ice hockey
c'était des organisateurs et opérateurs
de dice ce qui constitue une raison
suffisante
je n'aborderai pas les détails
concernant qui ils sont et quelles sont
leurs rôles spécifiques
nous avons la capacité et les moyens de
mener à bien des missions
antiterroristes à l'horizon et nous
allons nous défendre
nous allons achever cette mission d'ici
la fin du mois nous l'avons dit rien n'a
changé pour nous dans le calendrier et
nous le ferons de la manière la plus
sûre et ordonnée possible et cela inclut
la possibilité de continuer à évacuer
jusqu'à la fin
et dernières évacuations se poursuivent
dans un climat de tension avec le risque
d'un nouvel attentat pour la france
elles ont pris fin hier une centaine de
ressortissants français et plus de 2600
afghans ont été exfiltrés les précisions
de nicolas petit et là medjahed
les images ont fait le tour du monde les
afghans qui grimpe à même la carlingue
d'un avion dans l'espoir d'être exfiltré
depuis la mi-août plusieurs milliers
d'entre eux m'ont été prise en charge
grâce aux efforts conjoints de la
communauté internationale partie
prenante des opérations l'italie annoncé
ce vendredi au lendemain de l'attaqué de
kaboul la fin de ces opérations par la
voix de son
des affaires étrangères
il y a beaucoup de citoyens afghans qui
attendent d'être évacués nous ne pouvons
plus faire avec les points et rien que
nous avons vu ces derniers jours mais
nous sommes prêts à travailler avec les
nations unies et les pays limitrophes de
l'afghanistan
halladay l'afghanistan initiant la phase
est doué maintenant commence la phase 2
très difficile dans laquelle il est
impératif de ne pas abandonner le peuple
afghan de ne pas abandonner les femmes
afghanes les filles afghanes
comme l'italie l'espagne le royaume uni
et la france ont eux aussi annoncé
mettre un terme à leur peau aérien le
désengagement rapide des forces
américaines en charge de la sécurité de
l'aéroport de kaboul est temps confirmé
à court terme et les conditions de
sécurité n'étant plus remplie sur
l'aéroport nos opérations d'évacuation
ont pris fin ce vendredi 27 août dans
des circonstances a exceptionnellement
difficile la france a évacué près de
3000 personnes qui s'ajoutent aux près
de 1500 afghane et afghans ayant
travaillé pour notre pays que nous
avions déjà mis à l'abri avant le 15
août en anticipation de la crise
actuelle
dans un contexte où la menace terroriste
reste très grande les etats unis ont
confirmé leur départ de kaboul le 31
août tout en affirmant qu'il
poursuivrait les évacuations jusqu'au
dernier moment pour les milliers
d'afghans qui n'ont pas eu la chance
d'embarquer le dernier recours sera sans
doute l'exode terrestre d'après l'onu il
pourrait y avoir jusqu'à un demi million
de réfugiés afghans supplémentaires
cette année sur les routes de la région
plus de deux millions deux cent mille
sont déjà accueillies par les voisins
iraniens et pakistanais
et si certains ont pu être évacués grâce
à l'aide de pays étrangers d'autres sont
bloqués sur place et doivent s'organiser
avec les moyens du bord depuis à la
prise de pouvoir des talibans et l'est
maintenant deux semaines ils sont
inquiets pour leur vie beaucoup
d'afghans ont déjà pris le chemin de
l'exil légalement pas ils franchissent
les frontières des pays voisins dont
l'iran où il trouve refuge dans des
camps farah mais qui
d'abord le soulagement puis l'inquiétude
de nouveau depuis la prise de kaboul des
dizaines de milliers d'afghans
franchissent la frontière iranienne
chaque semaine d'après l'organisation
internationale des migrations
ado garwin dans la province de meched
dans le nord ouest du pays des réfugiés
qui ont eu la chance de pouvoir
traverser la frontière pose le peu
d'affaires emporté avec eux sur le sol
iranien
nous souhaitons que la paix et la
sécurité revienne dans notre pays c'est
tout ce que nous demandons à l'onu nous
demandons également l'aide du pays
voisin l'iran grâce à dieu les iraniens
nous donne des visas et tout le reste
nous sommes satisfaits maintenant tout
le monde veut venir en iran nous
demandons à l'onu de faire attention à
nous de ne pas nous oublier beaucoup
d'afghans ont été déplacées tout le
monde est terrifié
des visas distribuer mes semblables à
une denrée rare ces derniers jours de
nombreux camps de réfugiés afghans
installés illégalement à la frontière
ont été démantelés par les autorités
iraniennes et les exilés renvoyés dans
leur pays et pour cause la relation
ambiguë entre la république islamique
d'iran et les talibans en début d'année
le ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères mohammad javad tarifs
recevait à téhéran le mollah abdul ghani
baradar est une délégation talibane le
but de cette rencontre
stabiliser sur le long terme les
relations entre pays voisins et par la
suite consolider les relations entre
l'iran la chine et la russie
ainsi après la chute de kaboul le
président iranien s'était réjouit du
départ des occidentaux de la région la
défaite militaire et le départ des
etats-unis d'afghanistan doivent se
transformer en opportunité d'établir la
sécurité et une paix durable dans ce
pays l'iran tient à avoir des relations
de bon voisinage avec l'afghanistan
résultat téhéran qui optent pour une
position modérée face aux talibans
n'accepte plus l'établissement d'exilés
afghans sur son territoire mais les
laisse transiter vers la turquie où les
réfugiés ne sont plus les bienvenus
ils facturent l'eau dix fois plus cher
aux afghans turquie pour nous faire
partir mais où peuvent aller les afghans
le monde entier sait qu'il ya une guerre
chez nous maintenant je le dis à recep
tayyip erdogan ma mère et mon père ont
été décapités recep tayyip erdogan est
un musulman pas un non croyant mais un
musulman ma mère et mon père ont été
décapités il devrait m'aider ma mère et
mon père sont morts ou est-ce que je
peux aller
ces derniers jours le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan a accéléré la
construction d'un mur long de 243 km à
la frontière avec l'iran son but stopper
un flux migratoires potentiellement
semblable à celui que son pays a connues
en 2015
l'afghanistan au coeur des
préoccupations en irak où se trouve
emmanuel macron pour deux jours le chef
de l'état participé aujourd'hui à bagdad
à un sommet réunissant plusieurs
dirigeants du moyen-orient il était
notamment question de la stabilité de la
région et emmanuel macron a également
appelé à poursuivre la lutte contre le
terrorisme qui menace l'irak et les pays
voisins une lutte que la france mènera
avec ou sans l'appui américain
déclaration donc du président français
est plus
quels que soient les choix américain
nous maintiendrons notre présence pour
lutter contre le terrorisme en irak
aussi longtemps que les groupes
terroristes continueront à opérer et
aussi longtemps que le gouvernement
irakien nous demandera cet appui ce sont
les deux seules conditions qui sont les
nôtres et nous avons mené les études qui
me permettent de vous dire que nous
avons les capacités opérationnelles pour
assurer cette présence quels que soient
les choix américain nous adapterons
notre dispositif parce que la france a
toujours une même ligne nous luttons
contre le terrorisme islamiste et quels
sont les enjeux de ce sommet régional en
irak éléments de réponse avec une s
belle fait la consultant en relations
internationales et spécialiste du ah ben
c'est un sommet qui regroupe les pays
arabes la turquie l'iran et ça c'est
très rare de voir dans cette danse est
dans cette région on est en train
d'avoir un nouveau paysage de cette de
cette région c'est une occasion pour les
américains de consolider leur alliance
avec les pays concernés face à une
percée de nouveaux acteurs dans la
région principalement la russie et la
chine il faut aussi rappeler que durant
ce sommet il ya deux absents israël qui
est un acteur majeur dans la région
surtout après la normalisation de ses
relations avec beaucoup de pays d'arabes
et également la syrie qui passe par une
phase de reconstruction et de transition
et qu'il n'arrive plus à avoir une
certaine reconnaissance
internationale on est en train d'activer
la politique on est en train de donner
la chance à la diplomatie de résoudre
des problèmes certainement structurels
dans cette région est avec ses zones de
conflits l'afflux de migrants figurent
parmi les inquiétudes des pays de
l'union européenne notamment la pologne
l'armée a commencé à ériger une barrière
physique le long de sa frontière avec la
biélorussie le contingent militaire dans
cette zone vient de doubler à 2000
soldats l'union européenne soupçonne
minsk de diriger le flux de migrants
irakiens et afghans vers ses frontières
en guise de représailles contre les
sanctions imposées par bruxelles les
détails avec françois tiscali tx
des militaires polonais safer près de la
ville frontalière de crimes qui leur
mission
construire une clôture en barbelé d'une
hauteur de deux mètres cinquante et
d'une longueur totale de 180 kilomètres
le long de la frontière avec la
biélorussie
objectif empêcher les migrants de
pénétrer sur le sol européen un projet
qui divise les habitants de la région
cela ne me dérange pas je pense que
c'est nécessaire dans cette situation je
soutiens la position de la pologne
nous voyons tous les jours comment les
gardes-frontières travail ici combien
d'efforts ils déploient pour maîtriser
la situation
il semble que ce mur soit simplement
nécessaire
pour les gens ce ne sera pas une
barrière parce que la clôture qui les
installe ses poteaux vont s'effondrer
après quelques épisodes de pluie
je met l'argent dépensé sera énorme
quand j'entends que les quelques
kilomètres qu'ils construisent ont coûté
150 millions d'euros où va vraiment cet
argent
était payant de jeff koons au poker
selon les chiffres communiqués par les
gardes-frontière polonais depuis le
début du mois d'août plus de 3000
tentative de traversée ont été
enregistré un afflux de migrants
planifié systématiquement organisée par
minsk selon les premiers ministres des
pays baltes et de la pologne tandis que
l'europe dénonce une forme de
représailles du gouvernement biélorusse
au censure imposée par bruxelles
dans ce camp de fortune à quelques
mètres de la ligne de démarcation
des dizaines de migrants d'origine
afghane et irakienne sont bloqués depuis
plusieurs semaines les ong locales ont
l'interdiction de les approcher et leur
situation se dégrade
probablement en raison du mauvais temps
de plus en plus de migrants présentent
des symptômes de rhume
il y a aussi une femme âgée de 52 ans
elle est en mauvais état et ne veut pas
quitter la tente tiens je me sens pas
renié
l' agence de l'onu pour les réfugiés le
conseil de l'europe et la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ont
tous exhorté la pologne à fournir une
aide humanitaire aux migrants pour le
moment varsovie s'y est opposée arguant
qu'elle ne pouvait apporter son aide
sans le consentement des autorités
biélorusses
on ouvre le dossier du nucléaire iranien
rien n'a changé depuis donald trump
c'est ce que reproche le guide suprême
ali khamenei à joe biden le président
américain a affirmé hier au premier
ministre israélien naftali bennett que
les états unis ferait en sorte que
l'iran ne développe jamais une arme
nucléaire une annonce à laquelle a
répondu l'ayatollah khamenei
pour l'attaquant l'onu en bloquant
l'administration américaine actuelle
n'est pas différente de la précédente
car ce qu'elle exige de l'iran sur la
question nucléaire est la même chose que
ce que trump a exigé et qu'à l'époque de
hauts responsables du gouvernement
iranien on dit qu'il n'était pas
possible et prudent d'accepter ils
veulent la même chose aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas différent trump l'adie d'une
certaine manière et cela le dise en
utilisant des mots différents
nouveau samedi de mobilisation contre le
pass sanitaire le septième plus de cent
cinquante neuf mille personnes ont
protesté contre l'extension du passani
terre dans toute la france ces opposants
ont une nouvelle fois dénoncé et la
restriction de leur liberté notamment
avec l'obligation du pass annie terre
pour les salariés obligations qui entre
en vigueur dès lundi notamment dans les
cinémas salles de sport ou encore les
grands magasins à paris plusieurs
cortèges sont une nouvelle fois tenu
contre l'extension du pass and it est
réunissant plus de 14000 personnes ont
fait le point avec notre reporter n'a
déjà de razac une marche politique et
citoyenne organisée par le collectif
paris pour la liberté le rassemblement a
commencé à place denfert-rochereau en
début d'après-midi alors les
manifestants avaient pour objectif de
manifester devant le ministère de la
santé ils ont reçu un refus catégorique
de la part de la préfecture de police de
paris alors le parcours et s'est
finalement achevée boulevard du
montparnasse quoi qu'il en soit ils sont
des milliers à avoir manifesté pour dire
non au pass annie terre non à
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions et non à la vaccination des
plus jeunes je vous propose d'écouter
certains manifestants que l'on a pu
interroger tout à l'heure j'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on peut admettre que
la vie d'avant qui était d'aller
normalement au restaurant d'aller
normalement dans une salle de sport
enfin vivre vivre normalement
aujourd'hui on soir il veut arriver au
niveau de la chine où on doit avoir un
permis ce que j'ai écrit l'un a permis à
points pour avoir une vie une vie
normale la vie d'avant la vie la vie
tout simplement pas aller dans les cafés
une et à mesure des terrasses alors que
tout le monde parfois on est la distance
on respecte la justesse des barrières
c'est inadmissible et en tant que
soignant pendant la pandémie tout le
monde était aux hôtels sont placés en
assurer un dan simmons et maintenant les
montrer du doigt c'est c'est comme si on
était pestiféré je suis contre la
vaccination obligatoire
si on ne vaccine look de force c'est
comme si notre corps leur appartient si
on nous était un chef quelque chose pour
vous qu'est ce qu'il peut faire de pire
il peut pas faire quelque chose de pire
parce qu'ils peuvent maintenant notre
corps tout ce qu'ils veulent moi ça se
soigne en gt en première ligne pour les
corridas on a sacrifié notre vie impasse
sanitaire une obligation vaccinale pour
certaines professions de dispositifs de
lutte contre la propagation du comité 19
qualifier
liberticide par de nombreux manifestants
ici présents dont l'organisatrice de ce
rassemblement sophie tissier qu'on
soutient fondamentalement les paires
soignants qui subissent cette obligation
de vaccination et l'échéance arrive donc
absolument quant à ce monde et un grand
mouvement citoyen et pacifique
c'est pour ça qu'on est en blanc parce
que c'est la couleur de la paix et la
démocratie etc les blues but rageur
voilà donc on soutient évidemment les
soignants compte cette obligation et on
dénonce le l'instauration se passe
sanitaires on considère comme étant
vraiment le summum du contrôle des
citoyens on est en pleine dictature
sanitaire masqué alors parce que on a ce
mentalise la peur de ce virus dont on se
sert de la peur sur les gens pour leur
faire passer toutes ces lois scélérates
dictatorial donc ce n'est plus possible
en s'opposant aux livres citoyens a
envie de pacific tous ensemble sans
parti mener son officine politisé et
cette mobilisation aujourd'hui c'était
une sorte de répétition générale pour la
grande mobilisation du 11 septembre
prochain qui doit notamment réunir des
personnels de santé des pompiers ou
encore des gendarmes et tous ceux
finalement qui s'opposent au pass annie
terre et à la vaccination obligatoire et
des manifestants qui ont certainement
pour objectif de faire reculer le
gouvernement sur ces deux dispositifs
et parmi les différentes manifestations
qui se sont tenues à paris celle lancée
à l'appel de florian philippot le chef
de file du mouvement des patriotes
déterminés à poursuivre la mobilisation
contre le passe à lithaire qu'il
considère comme liberticide et français
voile usage ce que c'est que ce pas
salutaire
voit que ça n'a rien de sanitaires que
c'est une politique de restriction de
liberté que beaucoup de pays sont en
train de s'en débarrasser que ce qu'on
avait promis le tout vaccinal les restes
sont divertis elle passe à lithaire
étant la clé 100 m ça ne fonctionne pas
et est qu'il faut revenir à des choses
beaucoup plus sereine limitons le
danemark le danemark se débarrasse de
son pass le 1er septembre va récupérer
toute sa vie normale le 10 septembre
ouais c'est ça peut faire on reçoit des
périodes des publics vulnérables soigner
les gens à la résignation n'est pas dans
l'esprit français voilà quand l'esprit
il faut leur français se lève qu'il se
réveille il va jusqu'au bout et on
obtiendra à la fin de cette loi de la
honte la fin du pass de la honte aux
antilles les soignants ont gagné verront
à tenir bon vas y aura pas pour
l'instant de vaccination colis de bien
tard pour les soignants parce qu'ils se
sont mobilisés qu'ils ont résisté alors
c'est au peuple qu'on sépare tout
métropole et outre-mer de le faire parce
que sinon ce gouvernement continuera
dans le mépris et nous on en a marre du
mépris et pour en parler on retrouve bou
nommé garbade chefs de service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france on vient d'entendre
florian philippot parler du pass de la
honte c'est son expression quel regard
vous portez sur les détracteurs de ce
pas salutaire
écoutez je comprends que l'on puisse
contester discuter le passe à me taire
parce qu'effectivement
il entame un tout petit peu les libertés
individuelles maintenant il faut bien
comprendre pourquoi les autorités
sanitaires ont dû passer par ce pas ça
ni terre d'abord parce que la
vaccination contre la copie de plafonner
à niveau trop bas
menaçant la population à la rentrée d'un
risque
d'un nombre considérable de patients que
l'hôpital public ne pourrait pas soigné
et qui contraindrait à mettre en place
un confinement strict comme on l'a connu
au cours de la première vague épidémique
alors on va dire évidemment on aurait
préféré tous expliqué avec le temps avec
des webinars des séminaires des cours
des interviews l'intérêt de la
vaccination
malheureusement le virus nous a pris de
court le variant delta s'est répandue de
façon très rapide un mois et demi avant
l'échéance qui était prévu ou prévisible
par les observateurs de fait
effectivement il n'y avait pas le choix
l'objectif principal de ce pas salutaire
et de contraindre ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés à se vacciner le plus
rapidement possible car évidemment il
risque de faire une forme grave de la
maladie voire de mourir s'ils étaient
contaminés et on sait aujourd'hui toutes
les études ont pour on va dire point
commun de démontrer formellement que le
vaccin
protège de façon très importante contre
ce risque vous travaillez en service de
réanimation vous constatez concrètement
que les personnes hospitalisées pour
parce qu'elles sont atteintes par le
kobe 19 sont sont majoritairement des
personnes non vaccinées
c'est pas majoritairement c'est la quasi
totalité des patients hospitalisés en
réanimation aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas
vaccinés d'ailleurs ceux qui le sont et
qu'ils ont quand même fait une forme
grave de la maladie sont des personnes
immunodéprimées c'est à dire des
personnes qui ont un cancer évolue et
qui ont une transplantation d'organes
qui prennent des médicaments
immuno suppresseurs et donc de fait ça
n'est pas le vaccin qui n'a pas
fonctionné c'est simplement l'organisme
qui est un système immunitaire
totalement déprimé qui n'a pas pu
répondre à la vaccination
donc lorsque on n'a pas de problème de
santé particulier quels que soient les
comorbidités en dehors de
l'immunodépression et bien le vaccin
protège parfaitement contre le risque de
faire une tournée grave et donc
évidemment il permet de sauver des vies
c'est ça qui est important car il ne
faut pas penser que être hospitalisés en
réanimation et est un petit voyage
tranquille sera avec des traitements
facile pour pouvoir s'en remettre
malheureusement c'est une épreuve
extrêmement difficile avec des
traitements très invasif et avec au bout
un risque très élevé de décéder plus de
la moitié des personnes qui sont intubés
ventilé malheureusement risque de
décéder selon as les derniers chiffres
du ministère de la santé on en est à
près de 43 millions de personnes qui ont
reçu les deux doses prescrites est-ce
que c'est suffisant est ce qu'on arrive
en tout cas un chiffré qui commence à
être
rassurant selon vous
alors vous avez raison effectivement
justement grâce au pass sanitaires
la vaccination a bien progressé cet été
en france donc aujourd'hui plus des
trois quarts de la population a reçu au
moins une dose et près de 60% de la
population a reçu les deux doses donc
est complètement vaccinés
effectivement la question est de savoir
est ce que à ce niveau de vaccination de
la population on pourra tellement
déconnectés des couples et la
progression des contaminations que l'on
sait inéluctable à partir de la mi
septembre avec la reprise et de la vie
sociale et économique avec la
réouverture des écoles
avec le refroidissement des températures
et bien sûr les hospitalisations pour
des fois me grave de lakovic 19 alors on
ne sait pas exactement quel est le
pourcentage de vaccination de la
population qu'il faudrait pour découpler
ces deux phénomènes alors par analogie à
ce qui se passe par exemple en islande
de la population est très largement
vacciner aux environs de 85 à 90% là on
observe un parfait découplage donc
l'épidémie le virus circule d'ailleurs
le nombre de contaminations n'a jamais
été aussi élevé dans l'histoire de
l'épidémie en islande par contre il n'y
a quasiment aucun patients en
réanimation et il n'y a pas de décès
depuis plusieurs semaines merci donc ça
montre bien que la vaccination permet de
découpler transformer une infection
potentiellement létale finalement une
infection plus bénigne qui s'apparente
plus à un problème de grippe ou de rhume
et c'est l'objectif de la vaccination
merci beaucoup bruno m'égare ban pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes chef du service réanimation à
l'hôpital lariboisière et médecins
craignent matters merci à vous
voilà pour cette édition merci à de
l'avoir suivi prochain journal dans une
trentaine de minutes
[Musique]
je
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo le
haut du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
sb c'est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale vis
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de kia et
de cet appel d'air justement où vos
recrutements là malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]